thank you everyone for coming to the
second
Frankie lecture the fall term just a
very brief introductory remarks without
the Frankie lectures Barbara and rich
Frankie have generously made this series
possible it is a series designed to
appeal to a wide and generally audience
addressing topics about the relationship
to the humanities and the sciences about
different kinds of knowledge different
approaches to epistemology relations
between literature and science and not
just that but many other things so we're
very grateful to Barbara good Frankie
for that too in terrassa T and Annette
thoughtfulness that's why we're here so
welcome everyone to the second lecture
for about the franking seminar for this
fall term today we are honored and
delighted to have Ross Posner who is
Anna Carpathian professor in the
humanities at Columbia University
professor post-ops books include Henry
James in the problem of Robert Browning
then after that the trial of curiosity
Henry James William James and the
challenge of modernity notes from Oxford
in 1991 that book is generally thought
to be the single best work out there on
the brothers James and if you're
interested in the relation to Henry
you should look at Brussels with the
tribal curiosity it's an excellent book
he's also the author of color and
cultured black writers in the making of
the modern intellectually from Harvard
in 1998 and most recently the author of
Philip Roth's
moved truth the art of immaturity that's
from Princeton 2006 the titles rude
truth may echo for some of you a line
from Emerson self-reliance I got to walk
upright at the Bible that speak the rude
truth in all ways we have Minds right
okay so that's an appropriate thing ever
Sony and echo in the title of books but
Ross is also the editor of the Cambridge
companion to Ralph Waldo Ellison editor
2005 and he also ends the series
Cambridge studies of American literature
and culture he's on the editorial board
of Raritan and American literary history
in 1994 professor cosmic was awarded a
Guggenheim Fellowship and in 2009 he was
elected to the American Academy of Arts
and Sciences he is also a regular
contributor of essays and reviews to the
nation new republic husband is currently
at work on a bill about writers artists
and philosophers who renunciate or
renounce some aspect of their lives
among men Emerson
in Shiva many understanding the visual
arts and music and philosophy and prose
the talk he would give to language I'm
going to assume it's up to some extent
it certainly starts okay it's called
thanks very much professor Grimstad and
for the invitation I want to start with
two interlocking facts about Emerson and
his avid admirer Nietzsche the first is
the biographical fact of renunciation
they both quit soul killing institutions
citadels of conformity and formalism and
the second fact is a shared commitment
to enlarging philosophy beyond simply
the intellectual labor that produces
sermons and articles and eBooks
renunciation is the pivot by which each
man brings life and work together in a
dynamic unity such continuity makes them
akin to the ancients for whom philosophy
was a way of life rather than a
compartmentalized subject matter this is
a the consuming interest of Pierre IDO
the great French historian in my papers
second part I'll heed the imperative to
bring life and work together and give an
account of that unity from my own
experience to maximize the urgency of
abandoning one's sterile profession
Emerson and Nietzsche construct a sturdy
dichotomy of life versus books that is
as simplistic and contradictory as it is
inspiring they in effect sacrifice
intellectual subtlety on the altar of
life's exigencies in short the dichotomy
is catalytic it functions above all as a
way to produce the emotional momentum
needed to renounce or to use an
Emersonian word to make a transition
from from institutional affiliation for
Emerson the Unitarian ministry for
Nietzsche a university department of
classical languages of the move to a
less disciplinary place where a genius
whom Nietzsche defines as he who wants
to augment nature with new
living nature might thrive end quote the
very last place that thriving would
occur is in an academic chair where as
Nietzsche says beat one is obligated to
think in public about predetermined
subjects at predetermined hours and he
says this makes philosophical thought
quote emasculated from the first so he
wasn't long for the Academy his strategy
is a counter strategy to quote educate
ourselves against our age he seeks
liberating philosophical exemplars men
of genius those of quote unconstrained
and unhampered natural being whose books
are less intellectual than quote
physiological experiences that produce
quote the magical outpouring of the
inner strength of one natural creature
on to another reading Schopenhauer
produced this rapturous exchange yet
it's very medium robbed it of full power
each informs us but I had discovered him
only in the form of a book and that was
a great deficiency so I strove all the
harder to see through the book and to
imagine the living man just as William
James upon whom whose infant form
Emerson bestowed a blessing according to
James family lore just as William James
in 1907 will urge his auditors to quote
return to life and not let his lecture
quote teach the lesson he urges us to be
deafened to talk he says James Nietzsche
esteems what the book cannot encompass
the outward life in its corporeal
presence what he calls the quote
courageous visibility of the
philosophical life this is a grievously
absent in Germany where it can't
this is Nietzsche's favorite example
clung to his University submitted
himself to its regulations and his
example produced only quote professorial
philosophy and professed and professors
quote Kant has had a living and life
transforming influence on only a very
few men
end quote what counts for Nietzsche is
to abandon that half life in the Academy
and achieve courageous visibility
equality inherited from the ancient
Greeks who taught according to Nietzsche
through their very bearing through what
they wore and what they ate and their
morals rather than what rather than by
what they said let alone by what they
wrote
so Diogenes the cynic for instance is a
great favorite example for for Nietzsche
disturbing thinker he actually links to
Emerson the thinkers physical baring
embodied and caught every glance in
every gesture expresses the fused unity
of body and spirit and this insistence
on life as a whole undergirds their
commitment to visibility and counts as
their most valuable teaching although
Nietzsche for a taught for a decade in
the compared comparatively free-thinking
environment of Basel Switzerland
Nietzsche in 1879 left the University
and left the invisibility of his
professorship in Greek language and
literature with its heavy teaching load
and that was burdening as always
precarious health thanks in part to a
generous yearly pension from the
University he never needed another job
thus fulfilling what he called his
public promise made five years earlier
in Schopenhauer as educator from which
the above quotations derive in this
essay Nietzsche twice Koch quotes from
Emerson circles to inspire his own
effort of emancipation from the shackles
of professional philosophy and he
anticipates the opening of William
James's pragmatism which mocks quote the
refinement and rationalism that
insulates sterilizes classroom
philosophy that they're all very much of
a piece William James Nietzsche and
Emerson about this
Nietzsche declares quote and this again
is very James II and the only critique
of a philosophy that is possible and
that proves something in the Academy is
namely trying to see whether one can
live in accordance with it that's never
been taught all that's ever been taught
is a critique of words by means of other
words end quote
to escape the closed circuit of language
Nietzsche embraces the what embraces
life and will consign books for the
scholars idle time
to borrow Emerson's famously perverse
phrase in the American scholar but the
animus against the bookish grows deeper
as Nietzsche makes clear a philosopher
he says is not merely a great thinker
but also a real human being and when did
a scholar ever become a real human being
so this is the the severity of
Nietzsche's animus again it's somewhat
theatrical I think Emerson posed the
same question about preachers who can
forget his portrait and Divinity School
address of the preacher who sorely
tempted Emerson says to say I would go
to church no more this is a famous
passage you might know a snowstorm was
falling around us the snowstorm was real
the preacher merely spectral and the eye
left and the I felt the sad contrast and
looking at him and then out of the
window behind him into the beautiful
meteor of the snow the preacher had
lived in vain he had not one word
intimating that he had laughed or wept
was married or in love if he had ever
lived and actively were none the wiser
for it
end quote 1838 the same year as this
address to the Harvard Divinity students
is when Emerson fills his notebooks with
discontent about being a preacher just
for the record in 1832 he had resigned
the ministry of Boston's second church
but lately had agreed to preach each
Sunday at the East Lexington church so
he was still in touch with that apparent
from the notebooks is that Emerson's
second resignation from the Unitarian
Church is above all a dispute over
language he's frustrated at the
strictures of the ministry places on the
way language is to be used in the pulpit
to renounce the church is to renounce
its approved mode of preaching language
and the service of the formulaic that is
language wholly indifferent to the task
Emerson comes to see as crucial finding
ways to write and speak sentences that
approximate the volatility that courses
through nature and human being his
journal entries from near the near this
time of about 1838 quitting is there
there at once blunt and intricate quote
I hate goodies I hate goodness that
preaches
goodness that preaches undoes itself a
little a little electricity of virtue
lurks here and there in kitchens and
among the obscure chiefly women and it
flashes out occasional light and makes
the existence of the things still
credible goodies make us very bad we
will almost sin to spite them true to
the perverse pulse of life paraded
goodness sparks and spectators its
opposite desire to sin that's basically
Emerson's logic here Emerson reprises
his contempt for what he earlier derided
as quote official goodness preordained
itself advertised virtue that distracts
us from noting unscripted outcroppings
of actual virtue in class and gender
precincts out of bourgeois bounds quote
goodness that preaches undoes itself
meaning it logically negates itself but
Emerson's imagery of an electric charge
inherent in our part of something that
flashes out with light in a sort of
involuntary natural process helped solve
the logical problem he set up for
himself in defining goodness as
self-contained if goodness or virtue
exists in itself and silently how could
you ever know it's there
virtue or a goodness of its to be
communicated has to be done so
involuntarily as an actual force like
electricity it does it does exist
without being known and that's proved by
the incalculable way in which it comes
to be present he states quote I find in
me no enthusiasm no resources for the
instruction and guidance of the people
when they shall discover that their
present guides are blind this is a
notebook remark he continues this this
convention of Education is cold
I hate preaching weather and pupae
weather in pulpits or teachers meetings
preaching as a pledge and I wish to say
what I think and feel today with the
proviso that tomorrow perhaps I shall
contradict at all preaching is lifeless
because it's stymies the very rhythm of
life to be sliding in his word not fixed
teeming with excess and opposites
dualities and contradiction depending on
fixity and coherence in
Russian guide us repress and simplify
thereby seducing congregants into
obedience sapping their capacity to
think for themselves and the same
penalty afflicts he who dispenses
guidance it is a pledge whose cost it
too high diminished responsibility and
responsiveness in the present he notes I
always find that my views chill or shock
people and no wonder for it for in
setting words in motion they as if
generate the electric charge is talking
about quote the shock whereas in
contrast a minister he says nowadays is
plainness prose the prose of prose so
that the moralizing drone of quote
odious religion extol vacuous goodness
for Emerson again this is all carefully
set up for his departure the severance
from received ideas that Emerson and
Nietzsche offer is an ordeal by fire
each author writes texts that undermine
their own authority and the readers
reliance on that authority let me or let
me put it this way they seek to induce a
renunciation in the reader that mimes
the renunciation that first brings the
text into being when he says for
instance I unsettle all things Emerson
can be understood as speaking of a will
to severance that spreads from the
church ministry to the readers
dependency on him Nietzsche to values
what unsettles for him the capacity of
what he calls being perplexed and this
is a he says as the origin of philosophy
not simply wonder the ancient basis of
philosophy but being perplexed is
essential for encouraging critical
thought the commitment to unsettlement
losing one's bearings is therapeutic a
means of inducing change a return to
life of William James phrase rather than
an abiding with books but the return is
to a life stripped of a governing
hierarchy mine no longer proceeds and
defines experience but instead grasps
what Heidegger calls the quote unthought
background of thought the non conceptual
receptivity and feeling that's under the
raid
of cognition blind intuitive tacit as
one quote we do something without
knowing how or why the famous phrase to
describe Emerson's notion of abandonment
or transition which is analogous to what
Nietzsche calls the innocence of
becoming these are zones of the in
articulable we're doing without knowing
prevails and we must trust our own
feelings left on their own by
disorienting or enunciate in text
untethered readers face an uneasy
emancipation at this point I want to
take seriously their injunctions to
renounce the book and return to life to
be left on my own to exhibit if not
exactly a courageous visibility then at
least a turn mildly autobiographical I
want to show how both writers in their
shared devotion to exposing the limits
of rational deliberation help illuminate
helped illuminate a perplexity or
opacity in my own life and in so doing
they sharpen my frustration with the
pervasive rationalism of our most
prestigious intellectual paradigm
post-modernism and some here is my
testimony to the core living and life
transforming influence that Emerson and
Nietzsche both seek perhaps like me you
have a propensity to collect books
without quite knowing why over the years
I've piled up volumes by by and about
save it consign Hannah Arendt George
Santayana Philip Roth at Reinhardt
Philip Guston Franz Rosen's by Penelope
Fitzgerald Philip brief a motley crew
and not only not read them but not had
any not but did not have any desire to
read them I am I was busy working on
other things and for a decade or two
they simply gathered dust on my shelves
but then inevitably I will I would be
drawn to these nearly forgotten volumes
and strangely they would prove pivotal
to a new project I recall for instance
that santiana ascended literally from
the obscurity of a low shelf to earn a
chapter in my book on William and Henry
James
Wittgenstein made an analogous if more
circuitous journey from the shadows
waiting untouched until five years ago
when I kept a long-held inner vow to
read
another languishing tome one that it
stared me down so often it had acquired
an aura of intimidation Stanley Cavell
is the claim of reason but constancy up
toises immorality and tragedy
it was indeed intimidating but also
inspiring that experience opened the
door to more Cavell and to deeper
engagements with Emerson and to Vidkun
Stein who was joined the sage of Concord
and Nietzsche as a figure in a current
project mentioned in the introduction on
artists and philosophers and writers who
renounce their careers the peculiarities
of my manner of book-buying the absence
of full consciousness and the long gap
between acquisition and reading puts me
in mind of Walter Benjamin's famous
essay unpacking my library it starts
with the premise that quote every
passion borders on the chaotic and finds
that the passion of the book collector
unleashes a chaos of memories wherein
each purchase has been you mean chance
and fate and quote seem to jostle
against one another Benjamin who speaks
of his library as the quote accustomed
confusion of these books for what else
is this collection but a disorder to
which habit is accommodated itself to
such an extent that it can appear as
order for decades the chaos of my own
book collecting was a form of disorder
that blurred agency and intuition chance
and fate and though this this disorder
helped shape my intellectual life it had
been masked by habit and so escape my
reflective notice that is until a recent
encounter with a passage from Nietzsche
helps shed light but before that's
something else intervened to dunt to
nudge me to interrogate my habit around
2002 when I decided to write a book on
Philip Roth I had at hand most of his
novels having dutifully acquired them
over the years and true to form
remaining largely indifferent to reading
them so what they were just sitting
there but as I borrowed into Roth's work
however I grew aware of his close
friendship with the painter Philip
Guston a relationship that had become
basic to my understanding of what I was
then calling Roth's aesthetics of
immaturity that understanding was built
on what was also somehow at hand a pile
of monographs an article
the painter Philip Guston that that I
had carefully if inexplicably been
gathering over years now they were no
longer inert objects but palpable
presences both this patient stack of
Roth and Dustin material had undergone a
transformation that now struck me as
more than a serendipitous accident for
the first time I wondered what was going
on how did I explain my third my
thoughtless buying and deferred reading
what game was my unconscious playing it
seemed to be busy busily working
subliminally as it behind my mind's back
replacing deliberate effort with
intuition or instinct in order to
quicken receptivity keeping me in a
period of prolonged incubation as I
filled my shells in advance of my
conscious turned to works that would
prove crucial was it a professorial
enactment of what emerson called
abandoned abandonment the one thing
which we seek with insatiable desire as
he said to forget ourselves to do
something without knowing how or why in
short to draw a new circle this famous
passage which was the final paragraph of
his exhilarating essay circles it had
always been a personal favorite of mine
and a pedagogical touchstone in my
lectures but who knew I was living it
the possibility that I was indeed living
my own bookish version of abandonment
that I had unwittingly hence
appropriately been drawing Emersonian
circles apparently for decades this
sense this possibility Rasheed received
sharp confirmation last year teaching a
seminar at Emerson and Nietzsche I
encountered a passage from that latter's
autobiography ecce homo how one becomes
what one is section nine of why I am so
clever this at last crystallized matters
with brazen perversity Nietzsche
replaces the venerable venerable nada
motto know thyself he calls us now a
recipe for ruin with quote self
misunderstanding and describes his own
self becoming as a miracle of self
forgetting he begins by declaring quote
at this point the real answer the
question how one becomes what one is can
no longer be avoided the question
supposes that what this is Nietzsche
that one must not have the faintest
notion what one is from this perspective
again quoting even the blunders of life
the side paths and and wrong turnings
have their own meaning and value end
quote
as if Nietzsche acknowledges that one's
self estrangement awakened one from the
tunnel vision that plagues that certain
knower what Nietzsche portrays in ech a
homo homo is the coming to being of the
most innocent of cells in a sin as his
word that is one free from result Imam
and full of irresponsibility his word a
lightness gain from relinquish ngilgi
hoarded off permitting the quote surface
of consciousness to be kept clear of any
of what nietzsche calls the great
imperatives desires words attitudes all
of this is kept clear because they would
burden one with responsibilities and
goals and make one a man of knowledge
the grand words represent he says so
many dangers that the instinct comes too
soon
to understand itself and it will be
clogged with meaning keeping therefore
it and and keeping consciousness clear
this allows the eventual organizing
powers to grow in the dark as it were
quote deep down in the depths itself
with the capacity to reevaluate values
requires an especially intricate psychic
development quote contrary capacities
and quote must be cultivated and must be
carefully protected from awareness of
the quote secret labor of the instincts
Nietzsche tells us how he thrived as a
stranger to himself this is all
Nietzsche considered in this way my life
is simply wonderful
I've never even suspected what was
growing within me and one day all my
capacity suddenly right leap forth in
their ultimate perfection
I cannot remember having taken any
trouble no trace of struggle can be
demonstrated in my life I am the
opposite of a heroic nature willing
something striving for something and
visiting and visiting a purpose a wish I
know none of this from my experience
at this moment I will look upon my
future as upon a calm sea there is no
ripple of desire I do not want analyse
that anything should become different
than it is I myself do not want to
become different but that's how I've
always lived
I had no wishes a man over 40 for who
can say he never strove for honors or
for women or for money but it happened
for example one day I was a university
professor no such idea had ever entered
my head for I was barely 24 years old
and quote and why I am so clever
Nietzsche depicts himself here as a
veteran excuse me as a virgin of his
character Zarathustra that human being
redeemed from the spirit of revenge and
a herald of the ubermensch of course on
one level this self-portrait projects a
grandiose aristocratic fantasy of
immaculate effortlessness this is the
Nietzsche who was always for generations
intoxicated undergraduate aesthetes even
inspiring the famous lethal pair Leopold
and Loeb in Chicago in the 1920s rich
boys who were drunk on Nietzsche and
murdered a neighbor a young child yet
the self-portrait on one level grandiose
also deflates grandiosity by making
manifest the self overcoming that
Nietzsche Prizes when we experience the
impersonality of ourselves rather than
affirming our familiar sense of identity
this impersonality we are meaning we are
straight strangers to ourselves we do
not comprehend ourselves to recall his
words from the start of the preface to
the genealogy of morals strangers to
ourselves as a salutary rebuke to the
fantasy dear to the Western male psyche
of the sovereign individual as self
knowing master of experience willing
something striving for something and
visiting a purpose of wish I know none
of this from experience so Nietzsche is
renouncing the deliberative self who
formulates a plan of life as Jay s
Miller would would have it a plan of
life and renouncing know thyself and its
correlative to thine own self be true
as foolish Polonius put it nietzsche
challenges us to bear not knowing to
live without why in other words to let
instincts speak to us openly and it's it
also means to open new and hidden
energies in the self beyond the reach of
rational cognition that are normally
blocked in the act of self-reflection
Nietzsche in some loosens the hold of
the Cartesian cogito which makes knowing
subjects foundational he shares this
philosophic anti-intellectualism the
proposition that all experiences a mode
of knowing with among others his beloved
Emerson and his contemporary William
James
for instance William James's theory of
emotion insists on the primacy of the
body were afraid because we tremble
rather than the common sense opposite it
also includes as fellow into
anti-intellectual list Vidkun Stein who
says that one when one acts with
comfortable certainty one is to be
regarded as quote a creature in a
primitive state and when one follows
rules one does so blindly for these
figures as for John Dewey mind is
embodied and experience is not a
knowledge affair but rather is where
things are suffered and endured or had
before cognize that's Dewey's point
there had before cognized
the passage from why I'm so clever hit
home for it made sense of my own self
opacity the passage also made me feel
rather heady as if I was now licensed to
consecrate my blind book buying on the
altar of the Nietzschean ubermensch
Amazon unbound my temptation to self
transport seemed not wholly
inappropriate when I reflected that as
the Emerson each a seminar revealed on
more than one occasion
Emerson's praise of whim intuition and
ensue shion's seems at times to
intoxicate Nietzsche and inspire him to
new heights of rhetorical audacity after
the revelation afforded by a homo I
revisited Emerson's essay intellect to
see if it if it to extol the virtues of
self forgetting not only did the essay
offer more shocks of recognition but its
discomforting
that quote we have little control over
our thoughts thanks to the superiority
of the spontaneous or intuitive
principle over the arithmetic alors
logical end quote contain seeds that
flower in Ecce Homo spur trail of how
Nietzsche became what he is intellect
Emerson's essay also made explicit what
I had unwittingly lived that intuition
according to Emerson is a quote taking
in stride that has a complex temporality
since in Emerson's version of intuition
quote the mind does not immediately
Intuit what it has taken in stride
his idea of intuition and hence its
strangeness is counterintuitive as
Branka are such has shown in her subtle
reading of this essay long prior says
Emerson long prior to the age of
reflection is the thinking of the mind
out of darkness it came insensibly into
the marvelous light of today this lag
between thinking and reflection occurs
says are such because quote perceptions
affect one another in the intellect
without the mind knowing anything about
it
this explains why Emerson responding to
his rhetorical question quote what is
the hardest task in the world answers to
think this dramatically reverses the
Cartesian cogito remarks our shake our
siq here I is what cannot think what is
not entrusted with the power to think
she says Emerson notes that logic is not
absent in us but is quote virtual and
latent within the within the intuitive
principle logic he says is the
procession or a proportionate unfolding
of the intuition but its virtue is as
silent method the moment it would appear
as propositions and have a separate
value it is worthless
what makes thinking so hard and why
deferral is as if built into it is the
incorrigibility of our will it doesn't
control our power of thought what am I
Emerson asks what has my will done to
make me that I am nothing I have been
floated into this thought this hour this
Nexen of events by secret currents of
might and mind and my ingenuity and
willfulness have not warded have not
aided me to any appreciable degree our
truth of thought is therefore vitiated
'add this is all Emerson our truth of
thought is therefore vitiated it as much
by too violent direction given by our
will as by two great negligence we do
not determine what we will think we only
open our senses clear away as we can all
obstruction from the fact and suffer the
intellect to see we have little control
of our thoughts end quote
in other words intellect grow
spontaneously without effort some image
word or fact will imprint itself on our
mind and that adherence to gradually
germinates unfolding he says like a
vegetable bud he says your first and
instinct in an opinion than a knowledge
as the plant has root bud and fruit
trust the instinct to the end though you
can render no reason it's vain to hurry
it by trusting it to the end that shall
ripen into truth and you shall know why
you believe Nietzsche and Emerson shared
suspicions of the will to self-knowledge
and their trust in instinct also
precipitated my turn to another volume
that had spent decades untended on my
shelf michael polanyi's personal
knowledge when i described my pre
reflective literary habits as amounting
to a prolonged period of incubation I
borrowed this word from Palani his book
never read long owned and surviving
multiple moves it's crammed poorly
printed pages now made all the more
uninviting by thin yellowing paper and a
and a cracking paperback spine just I
was oblivious to it over the years they
lured by its title and some of its
headings the art of knowing intellectual
passions the tacit component I would
periodically rescue the book for my
chronic negligence taking it up in a
burst of enthusiasm only to set it aside
my impulse rebuked still too much
science I rationalized and besides the
print was a trial and the pages loose
but in the wake of my Nietzschean and
Emersonian induced epiphanies the moment
of personal knowledge had arrived I was
ready at last for its central point
which is quote we feel our way to
success well that's without specify ibly
knowing how we do it this tacit
dimension this is that's the title of a
better-known Palani volume is the quote
immense mental domain acquired he says
by effort which went beyond the hitherto
assured capacity of some person making
it it relied on an act of groping which
originally passed the understanding of
its agent and of which he has ever since
remained only subsidiary aware as part
of a complex achievement this was a meta
moment so prized by English professors
the work that celebrated groping
knowledge unspecified belén effable
unimpaired chol mirrored the very
groping I had long been tacitly
practicing most recently when I pluck
personal knowledge from my seeming
oblivion at a propitious moment trust
the instinct to the end Emerson said
though you can render no reason it's
vain to hurry it I seem to be confirming
that trust in feeling one's way
informally in the absence of conscious
action typifies what play Ani calls the
incubation period of discovery during
incubation nothing happens on the level
of consciousness or behavior even as
we're preoccupied unconsciously he says
the fact that our intellectual strivings
make effective progress during a period
of incubation without any effort on our
part is in line with the latent
character of all knowledge
personal knowledge is an is the magnum
opus of a distinguished Hungarian
chemist who abandons science for
philosophy politics and economics
personal knowledge from 1958 has always
been in the shadows of a more famous
work that it anticipates Thomas Kuhns
restructure scientific revolutions from
62 as Polly anees most recent biographer
remarks most people first know of him
from Koons remark in structure
commending his notion of tacit knowledge
polanyi's work which joined Koons as
foundational for the new field the
social construction of sign
argued for an alternative to the
positivist model of scientific inquiry
as unalloyed objectivity and rational
deliberation for Palani quote true
discovery is not a strictly logical
performance but requires plunges and
leaps across logical gaps he says in a
passage that grows increasingly lyrical
especially when we consider in a
scientific background
neither subjective nor objective but
transcending their opposition personal
knowledge is science in searches my
personal knowledge in science is not
made but discovered and as such it
claims to establish contact with reality
beyond the clues on which it relies it
commits us passionately and far beyond
our comprehension to a vision of reality
of this responsibility we cannot divest
ourselves by setting up objective
criteria of verifiability for we live in
it as the garment of our skin like love
to which it is attic in this commitment
commitment is to a shirt of flame phrase
of TS Eliot's assure to flame blazing
with passion and also like love consumed
by devotion to a universal demand such
as the true sense of objectivity in
science says plea on E so he joins
science to art and mysticism and
breaking through the screen of
objectivity drawing he says our pre
conceptual capacities of contemplative
vision capacity shared he repeatedly
shows by infants and chimpanzees like
James and Dewey Palani wants to rescue
experience from those observers and
instrumentalists who quote guided by
experience past through experience
without experiencing and experiences it
in itself they wanted to go through
experience without experiencing it what
happens what keeps us aloof from things
their sound sight smell and touch is the
very conceptual framework by which we
observe and manipulate things scientific
discovery demolishes one accepted
framework after another more to
construct another more rigorous one but
that act of revenge
and Discovery quote burst the bounds of
discipline thought in an intensive
transient moment of heuristic vision
overwhelmed by its own passionate
activity says plea ani this turbulence
of creative freedom that defies if for a
moment the bounds of discipline thought
recalls Kant's conception of genius as a
force of originality and different two
rules
hence the genius says conda's is in the
third critique does not himself know how
the ideas for it have entered into his
head nor has he in it in his power to
invent the like at pleasure or
methodically and to communicate the same
to others in such precepts as when
enable them to produce similar products
genius in other words dwells and the
tacit dimension it's well known that
post-modernism has no patience for
genius not least because it smacks too
much of allegiance to liberal humanism
fondness for sovereign subjectivity and
even some great man theory of history
but let's note it is that postmodern
theory tends to have a consistent blind
spot regarding the tacit dimension and
the precognitive in general symptoms of
their more pervasive suspicions of the
unmediated be it instinct sensation the
unconscious intuition the flashes of
responsiveness and receptivity generated
by the body as Nietzsche says in a gay
homo my genius is in my nostrils and in
the twilight of idols he mocks the
philosophers idolatry of reason reason
is what causes us to falsify the
testimony of the senses
whereas Nietzsche's naturalism provides
an actual history of moral norms which
is what he means by the notion of
genealogy post-modernism makes
unrelenting war on the natural this is
sort of it in the 80s 70s and 80s
Nietzsche was a hero of post-modernism
here I'm trying to suggest their
oppositional post-modernism makes
unrelenting war on the natural reducing
the self to an ideologically constructed
identity forms of intellectualism
pervade postmodern theory for instance
belief in the ubiquity of textualism
certainly the early Derrida rhetoric and
figure ality demand interpretations of
the
hoody of all these things interpretation
Stanley fish and intention of Walter Ben
Michaels one result is that they
postmodern theorists inadvertently
reinstate the gap between nature and
culture body and mind emotion and reason
and leave feeling or any immediate
experience or sensation under suspicion
as hopelessly naive interestingly its
visual artists and writers about art
who've been very receptive to this limit
in post-modernism because visual artists
often seem to embody or perform this
naivete immersed in the hands-on
interplay with paint and canvas they're
therefore and relatedly often evasive or
reticent regarding requests to stand
back and explain the meaning of their
art they sort of renounced that
responsibility but they're rich in tacit
knowing and intuition and this makes
them willing to follow what the
materials and hands seem to want to do
whereas literature as Demand famously
wrote is quote the only form of language
free from the fallacy of unmediated
expression and quote the practitioners
of visual art tend to tended to embrace
the fallacy of the unmediated in their
relish of the violence of sensation for
instance in his famous interviews with
david sylvester the painter Francis
Bacon speaks repeatedly of painting as
an effort to record quote one's own feet
one's own feelings as closely to one's
own nervous system as one possibly can
and quote in in effect it was the job of
postmodern art theorists to tidy up the
artists naive belief in the power of the
visceral which was grounded in
engagement with obdurate ly palpable
materials but postmoderns programmatic
suspicions over claims of naivete has
produced a counter response predictably
one that art historians have started to
articulate while one Richard Schiff in
his book doubt to 2008 says claims for
the ubiquitous efficacy of cultural
forces may be creating a more pernicious
mythology than belief in aesthetic
immediacy and naturalness
and quote shifts doubts about postmodern
orthodoxy leave him as he says hanging
his frayed he says it does not entail
being convinced of the real existence of
the natural self that certain artists
may be continuing to seek as a
liberating alternative to culture it
does not entail this rather our doubt
merely indicates how deeply
dissatisfying it is to believe that
there can be no natural self and no
physical existence at all no source of
sensation that might escape the
generalizing sameness of our various
cultural identities Schiff in short is
tired he says of being pressured by the
critical indoctrination which trains a
trains us he says all too readily to
expose the superficiality the
constructed spectacle the the Mirage of
sensation to distrust our feelings more
than to trust them Schiff asked quote to
what degree are we willing to trust and
act on feeling especially when no Theory
supports it he urges us to quote stop
conflating the history of the criticism
and theory of art with the history of
making art the former depends on what he
says is a fantasy world of the general
and conceptual that can only lead away
from the sensory world of the specific
and the real though theory encouraged
him to be quote extraordinarily wary of
many of the claims of modern artists
Schiff now tries to resist his own
distrust in his effort to keep faith in
feeling he enlists polanyi's personal
knowledge when asked in an interview
what's worth caring about Schiff says
that we need to understand our quote
cultural hunger to experience what
escapes conceptualization this hungers
deep in the American grain Emerson
called the hunger abandonment and his
greatest reader Nietzsche alerted me
last year that I too had this hunger for
decades I've been feeding it my own acts
of Biblio abandonment my intuitive book
buying the urge to quote do something
without knowing how or why and short to
draw a new circle thanks
sure yeah
Oh
did you have people in mind who were
happy
professors Oh in anthropology that Gong
welcoming Spiritual Exercises that's I
think Adele says yeah absolutely well I
think that's part of fuko's dislike what
he call the general intellectual that
would not be an Emersonian the
non-affiliated the specific intellectual
is inside right yeah I kind of agree
right you yes how far I want to go I
don't want to go too far III tried to
queue my quotations by saying that they
were theatrical izing but I wouldn't I
I don't know if I disagree but I I think
that the William James William James
starts pragmatism by mocking classroom
philosophy
it's a city on a hill and he says it
breathes refinement and he's
contemptuous of the Harvard his Harvard
colleagues in the department and he's
he's also using the word refinement to
extend to social gentility and their
indifference to social suffering poverty
and he talks about he has newspaper
clips that an anarchist had given them
about Oh Cleveland working man who
killed himself and his family from
poverty and he says this this is the
multitudinous street that the world the
world of that's beyond the university's
grasp this is what pragmatism 'he's
going to dwell in and that commit that
james een commitment is enormous ly
influential for people like Randolph
Bourne and the 20s intellectuals like
Mumford & & Van Wyk Brooks they're all
on Edmund Wilson they're all
unaffiliated they're they're firmly
Susan Santa Kenneth Kenneth Burke is a
teacher Susan Sontag at University of
Chicago Kenneth Burke is a later
generation mid-century version of the
unaffiliated he teaches occasionally but
he helps inculcate in Sonntag a adamant
almost instinctive contempt for
institutions
I mean if you read her journal she's
saying that something like when she's 18
years old I know I'm never gonna teach
in other words I hear exactly what
you're saying but there is a broad
Emersonian James Ian's current of anti
institutionalism
oh do you want to say you want me to say
the difference or imagine the difference
or do you want to tell me and I'll react
to it oh well I should say that I I
don't fetishize the word run a
renunciation of my own work if the
abandonment is more visceral for Emerson
it's more visceral more immediate I
think the way of life is wonderful it's
by abandonment to do something without
knowing how or why we're on CA ssin
could be much more intellectual formal
but what's your your
oh I see I think that the remember
either one is never forsaken if they're
not blotted out they are most interested
in acts of renunciation that then become
a compositional resource and the work of
the renunciate er like like Emerson for
instance or Nietzsche where the act of
renunciation is propelling their work
it's it's figured in their work but you
wanted to say something earlier
yeah that's interesting you mean if not
knowledge at least a receptivity
I mean it seems paradoxical from the
start
you mean to like to be spontaneous you
know to be yeah it's very tricky but it
may be that I'm Nietzsche and Emerson
are trying to do just that mm-hmm or
with the notion and that there was
discussed in class today about
impression ability for Emerson you can't
help but be constantly bombarded by
things in the atmosphere he says and so
you're always already intuitive way
beyond your rational capacities
the limiting property of it I guess
we're not renunciate errs are acutely
aware of limits or they insist on limits
I mean renunciation could be an act of
willful drawing of limits precisely to
feel frustrated I mean I think the
important thing in their theatrical is
that what I'm calling their theatrical
ization of their Animists about
institutions is is the need to gain
momentum to leave so feeling confined is
important for them you know in a way to
cultivate the way that people save James
Joyce cultivated his ambivalences toward
Ireland he needed to feel and flight
from it he was nursing it
that's fascinating
is there a lesson in the essay fate for
I'm not sure I certainly nothing leaps
to mind were you did you have something
in mind or unless unless we would insist
with Emerson that everything has its
opposite and that to embrace fate is to
embrace freedom at the same time and so
we could say post-modernism is failing
to heed Emerson's insistence on
opposites that things are and are not at
the same time you know that as he says a
nominalist and realist every every
sentence is true and untrue every
sentence holds a lie so the flight from
feeling in this in this strain of
post-modernism may be a kind of
impoverishment from not being in touch
with that vision of opposites perhaps
about the Kassadin implicit assumed
divergence or polarity between the
conceptual and the effective in your
topics you really accepted distinction
between here's a here are immediate
sensual sensory effects and they can be
undergone and felt and here's this other
realm which is the extracting
universalizing the conceptual the
linguistic casting everything in two
words somehow sterilizing the there's a
lot of from the pragmatism offers a
complex most blatant offender
lesson really kind of striking and
memorable way that's why we continue to
read them so what happens to your
distinction between the when you
consider in fact the latest sort of
developments and mutations in let's say
I would say Deleuze people like to lose
her or leotard or important counterpoint
I said a certain strain that's
influential had been influential
there's certainly important counter
strings probably I don't mean to
describe the situation right now I would
say with the advent of Delors and other
developments effect theory of course the
in a way the problems been solved and
you're absolutely right in terms of the
history of philosophy but literary
figures don't seem to worry too much
about these nuances but again back to
William James William James makes very
romantic on nuanced rejections of
concepts in his late work that but he
does say I'm not saying get rid of
concepts he's talking about not being
enslaved to them not taking them as
definitive yeah but it's in it's a
problem of degree of course we had we
were wedded to concepts but he then his
passion is to
critique what he calls the conceptual
decomposition of life getting back to R
or D for a minute Rorty is a completely
perverse figure because he purports to
be the the heir to Dewey and he has
absolutely no patience with the
pre-linguistic at all and so he write
well cuz he comes from an analytic
background and he didn't want to be
embarrassed by the flagrant romanticism
of James so he speaks of try to discern
your eyes - James when he's as he says
that diving into the bag Sounion flux
you know it's just an embarrassment to R
or D but I don't think that's a very
rich response to the fact that James is
interested in diving into the flux
Marx and Melville okay that's a very
important question we saw today in a
Emerson's essay fade it's an essay in
which slavery figures very quietly
unmistakeably but not forcefully and
sensually Emerson did rise to the
occasion when the abolitionists asked
him to join their cause in the early
1850s and he he insisted on anti-slavery
as a position but he he had a deeper
point we talked about it today earlier
that he had his own he said in a journal
entry that he had his own slaves to free
meaning readers you know man is timid
and apologetic a dwarf
yeah it's that's uh that's one of the
most incendiary moments in Emerson
that's completely infuriating to a lot
of readers and it's part of his
commitment to talking about what he
calls my slaves or in that passage my
poor are they my poor what he means by
that I think and I agree with Richard
Poirier who wrote about it that when he
says my poor he means people who are
spiritually poor impoverished and in
need of what he's talking about but he
wants us in our irritation with him at
that passage he wants us to start
parsing these distinctions
yeah that's what nature said you know
mm-hmm
you mean does it boil down to making the
move from the Academy to quote life
which is it which is the is the
problematic dichotomy that Nietzsche
leaves this one what it would have
boiled down to a philosopher who speaks
to the general public some
well John Dewey devote devoted he didn't
theorize it but he devoted his career to
the problems of men as he called he was
the great figure who less tormented than
William James carried on that effort for
various reasons historical reasons after
Dewey's death philosophy became very
professionalized turned inward
Rorty sought to emancipate himself from
that inward turn but and in some way
tried to be a Dewey for his age and in
some ways succeeded but the the audience
had already shrunk it he never had the
the the scale of an audience that it
James or a Dewey hand I mean it so in
other words it's a it's a problem that
doesn't just begin it's not just about a
thinker seeking a larger audience it's
it's also a sociological cultural
condition that impedes that possibility
unknowingly was the occasion projects
and appreciated but passions
because you weren't reading them enough
of them oh yeah I'm sort of taking a
benign example my own example but you're
right it's interesting to think of it
well or you could just generalize that
neurotic behavior is not is is behaving
without knowing why right you're the
repetition compulsion of doing the same
destructive thing so it's just a
different part of the continuum yeah
that's
or you could just you could say it leads
to a great library that maybe one day
you will stop and start to enjoy rather
than compulsively buying I mean you
don't have to consign it to await a
wasted actor of futility your relation
to the books could change over time no
it's a fascinating question
yeah go ahead no no I read her novel and
nivalis the blue flower amazing thank
you